let's get hot here the fires of Pompeii
yes folks it is time for another overdue
Doctor Who review but first oh we did
just bring your attention to the fact
that this review is brought to you by
radio versus the Martians this is a
podcast hosted by Mike Gillis and Casey
Doran as they talk about all manner of
geeky stuff they talk comics they talk
movies TV Star Trek Star Wars
superheroes ghostbusters
Conan the Barbarian in fact the entire
oeuvre of Arnold Schwarzenegger it's all
up for grabs
they have good guests they have great
discussions they're often funny and they
can even at times be insightful check
them out at Radio versus the Martians
calm or ever you get your podcasts I
think I'm getting the hang of this so
fires of Pompeii Donna's first actual
jaunt in the TARDIS you know to
somewhere notably different from where
she's used to being and again as before
the doctor and Donna Oh mwah like I love
these two together
so much I like the grief that she gives
him I I like the the fact that she's
just not gonna take no for an answer
from him that she's she knows he's an
amazing guy but she is not in awe of him
if he gives her an answer she doesn't
like she's gonna let him know that like
immediately it's so terrific and also
watching this one was interesting
spotting the actors who would come back
later in the show because we've got
Karen Gillan playing one of the
soothsayers in the Civil Lines
sisterhood and then we of course have
Peter Capaldi as
cake Ilyas uh I think that's what it was
I'm getting my the the Roman names
jumbled in my head now but you know he
was he was in an end so that's kind of
fun to watch that all pan out this one I
think the fact that I tend to resonate
at this point in my life more with the
emotional angles of things then used to
be the case I think I actually have a
better appreciation for this episode
than I did the first time I watched it
and I enjoyed it pretty well the first
time I watched it but I especially
towards the end with Donna's plea to the
doctor that that choked me up because
you could see the desperation and also
he had he had already made his decision
that he can't do anything but there's
something well first of all the
performances are astounding and then
there's just the fact that he needed
someone to remind him that just because
you can't save everyone doesn't mean you
can't save anyone
and these quote-unquote small lives have
value too and if you can save just this
one family that's that doesn't undo
everything else that is happening but
it's something and if he can do it he
should and he does with Donna's
promptings and I really do enjoy that I
do feel really bad for poor Peter
Capaldi though cuz he had to try him and
he tries so hard to sell this awful line
of it's like some sort of volcano like
it he's he's be he's trying to be all
emotional during his bone or like oh god
that line that hurt the other thing that
that this kind of reminded me of is that
while they're all tied to one thing the
series for actually has multiple mystery
boxes
cooking away and what I mean by that
because I've used this term before so
let me define it as I mean it when I
talk about Doctor Who Doctor Who series
Ark structure by and large has conformed
to what I call a mystery box which is
something that is hinted at named or
otherwise indicated early on in the
series and then repeatedly across it
until we find out exactly what is going
on with whatever that thing is in the
finale so in series one it would be bad
wolf in series to be Torchwood series
three votes axon and then later on you
know there's things like the cracks in
time the hybrid the the vault you know
all sorts of stuff like that series four
actually kind of has three at least
because well one of them is very sneaky
and you only kind of realize it in
hindsight but it's it's got planets
being lost which you know has now been
coming up two episodes in a row you've
got from the previous episode hey you
have rows and it's like wait what's
going on there and then you've got the
bees disappearing and it's kind of
interesting that that they have those
separate things cooking away until they
kind of pull together I think the bees
disappearing is the one that you that
you can miss because it is it is the
very least initially just brought up by
Donna like oh yeah and the bees are
disappearing and the doctors like what
oh but then they're busy with other
stuff but we we get the reiteration of
planets disappearing planets being lost
planets being stolen the pyro vials are
decent they work they work pretty well
if the overall setting and the
performances from the supporting yeah I
mean that the family that Peter Capaldi
is the head of that they are very solid
I enjoy them quite a bit the sisterhood
is fine you was something that I found
myself thing
as it went on this kind of poked that
nerve that I have that frequently with
depictions of people with some kind of
religious faith in media now this seems
like an odd episode for me to bring this
up as a subject because I mean like it's
ancient Rome what what are we even going
on about but I'm just lettin if I can
explain this in a way that that conveys
what's on my mind so something that
tends to bother me in general and you
see it most often in depictions of
Christians or at least I see it most
often in that is basically treating
people treating having faith almost like
it's a mental disability like they they
see something in them react in a way
that like makes absolutely no sense but
gets justified with oh but they have
faith so or you know just behave in a
very buffoonish manner that is validated
by always because of their faith I'm
like and that just tends to bother me
and so within the context of this
episode the reason I I'm bringing this
up is that oh and like for the record
I'm I don't have a formalized face I
wasn't brought up as anything so this
isn't like a de making fun of my
religion I don't have a religion it just
it's just low hanging fruit cheap shots
and I just don't enjoy it um but anyways
so coming back to this why this why I
felt this was relevant to bring up is so
we've got you know the seers we've got
the Sibylline sisterhood we've got the
town soothsayer and for those characters
I am okay because for them their faith
is like is like their job so like I'm
prepared to buy that they sort of go a
little bit more all-in on this stuff but
when average everyday people so like
when this big rock and magma monster
shows up in this house and
servant just goes the gods walk among us
and wanders towards this thing in order
to get burned up and prove how deadly
this thing is I immediately kind of go
no because I don't I don't care what
your faith is if you see a giant magma
monster even if such a thing is
justified by your religious beliefs if
you are a normal human being
your first thought is going to be oh
crap and you run like maybe later you're
validated in your head but you don't
just go oh the gods walk among us like
and like it gets justify it as a
combination of you know it it get it
gets treated as if faith makes people
stupid and that people bought into faith
to a degree much greater in the past
than they do now and I think honestly in
many cases that's debatable my own
thinking is that people in time like
ancient Rome probably took their faith
about as seriously as most people now do
which is to say they use it as a guiding
principle they use it to fill in some
gaps for some things that don't make
sense but it doesn't like override
rationality because I think like if most
people you know even deeply religious
people saw a burning figure in the sky
they wouldn't just wander towards and go
an angel they go oh my god and run so
you know I don't know I don't know why
I'm sticky on this so long but for some
reason it really hurt me this time so
Adam I don't know I've gone on some
weird tangents the last couple of
episodes I don't know why this stuff
sticking in my craw let's get back to
Doctor Who um not all of the effects of
aged especially well but some of these
are CGI heavy that said the designs are
pretty good unlike the big rock magma
monsters which I mentioned so those are
working pretty well
I like the doctor having to make the
kind of call that he doesn't want that
he never wanted to have to make again
which is to be trading lives to make
the decision these 20,000 people are
going to die in order to save billions
of other lives and you can tell you can
see the pain can see how much he hates
having to make that decision and I like
that he couldn't do it until Donna
helped and that Donna the person begging
him to stop the volcano or to evacuate
the city and him saying no I can't helps
him set that off because she knows it
has to happen and she knows he needs
help
this is not something she wants either
but this is how it needs to be and that
she is willing to literally put a hand
out and help her friend do something
that is really hard for him that's it
that's a great moment I love that a lot
they really kind of do put Donna through
the emotional wringer like right off the
bat like it's pretty standard that the
campaign gets put into physical danger
immediately but they they between this
in the next episode they give Donna a
rough go of it emotionally right off the
bat which again I think speaks in a lot
of ways to her strength as a as a
character that you know she would she
would come back after what she goes
through these first Hugo's would the
doctor I think I might wrap it up about
there I like I know I went on that
tangent there I do like this episode I'd
like ancient Rome in ancient Greece like
as settings both aesthetically and as a
general vibe so I'm a little bit of a
sucker for it it's not um an amazing
episode it has a couple of key great
moments again largely focused on the
doctor and Donna but also like some of
the guest stars do very well like
Capaldi and handled in that family of
characters they feel like a proper
family and that that works well and that
that helps sell the emotionality of the
ending of the episode quite well too so
let's wrap it up on that know what I
think
the fires of Pompeii you seen it what do
you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it there's a
whole bunch of stuff to do down there
such as for instance consider supporting
me on patreon you can get a look at
what's coming up for planned videos
early you can help vote on what topics
are gonna be access to the discord all
sorts of stuff so give a look at that
plus there's merch links to social media
the book I wrote all kinds of things you
can click on these things in like
they'll take you places where you can do
stuff you also don't need to do that
like I appreciate it but it's okay you
don't have to because at the end of the
day it's you who are the council and me
I'm just the weirdo in cosplay who runs
the meetings so until next time this
council is adjourned